brechen über einen mord nicht irgend ein
mord wenn es so etwas überhaupt gibt ein
mord unter teenies es ist das mordopfer
anastasia 15 jahre alt 15 erst- und
ihrem mutmaßlichen mörder freunde zwei
freunde jungs 13 und 14 jahre alt
das entsetzen ist groß die anwohner von
salzgitter gedenken der 15-jährigen
einer stasi an sie wurde ermordet
tatverdächtig sind zwei jungen fast noch
kinder die ebenfalls auf ihre schule
ging tatverdächtig sind ein 13 ein 14
jähriger aus salzgitter beide waren mit
dem mädchen bekannt das heißt man lebt
im selben viertel man ging zur selben
schule es hat vorher auch kontakte
gegeben zwischen opfer und täter das
tatmotiv der beiden die
staatsanwaltschaft sieht das motiv im
persönlichen bereich sowohl opfer als
auch täter haben einen russischen
migrationshintergrund wir gehen davon
aus dass es keine rolle bei der tat
gespielt hat auch anhaltspunkte für
sexualstraftaten gibt es keine wir sehen
das motiv eher im persönlichen bereich
offensichtlich hat sich da eine
freundschaft entwickelt zumindest aus
sicht der täter und das ist dann hier in
der tat letztlich eskaliert dass ein 14
und ein 13-jähriger zu solch einer
grausamen tat fähig sind schockiert die
anwohner also ich bin geschockt ja ich
wollen jetzt schon knapp 20 jahre und
dass da was passiert
fällt mir schwer das überhaupt zu
verstehen wie so was sagen kann
kann mich gruselig aber noch
fehlen die worte also für nicht ganz
groß aber ich kann es noch gar nicht
vorstellen wie man die man überhaupt
dazu in der lage sein kann und dann auch
noch in so einem jungen alter
nach quälenden tagen der suche fanden
die ermittler die leiche von anastasia
die obduktion ergibt sie ist erstickt es
ist die traurige gewissheit nach einer
tagelangen suche in der grünanlage
hinter mir einem ehemaligen
regenrückhaltebecken eine verwilderte
anlage dort lag der körper gefunden hat
in die polizei in dem sie gegen mittag
eine drohne mit wärmebildkamera
aufsteigen ließ und diese drohne
beziehungsweise die aufnahmen der drohne
brachten die traurige gewissheit die
15-jährige ist tot am sonntagabend geht
eine vermisstenmeldung einer 15 jährigen
schülerin bei der polizei in salzgitter
ein noch in der dunkelheit beginnen die
ermittler mit umfassenden suchmaßnahmen
setzen diese am nächsten morgen fort
teenager begehen so eine grausame tat
kein einzelfall in deutschland
fünfzehnter september 2021 großröhrsdorf
in sachsen anwohner finden ein
blutüberströmten körper in einem
garagenhof es ist die 16 jährige
victoria t ihr körper ist übersät mit
messerstichen die nachbarn alarmierten
die rettungskräfte doch die
einsatzkräfte kommen zu spät die 16
jährige stirbt noch am tatort
victorias mörder ihr damals 15 jähriger
mitschüler ermittler neben den teenager
wenige tage nach dem mord fest
vergangene woche verurteilte ein richter
ihn zu siebeneinhalb jahren haft ist
heute schweigt er inzwischen 16 jährige
zu seinem motiv victoria zu ermorden nur
zwei monate später erschüttert der
nächste mädchen norddeutschland nach dem
josephine haar aus aschersleben sechs
tage lang als vermisst gilt finden
ermittler die leiche der 14-jährigen
ermordet von ihrem gleichaltrigen ex
freund jonas k perfide lockt er josef
ihn in einen hinterhalt trifft sie an
einem abgelegenen ort schlägt sie brutal
nieder und sticht dann auch sie ein
nachdem jonas die 14 jährige ermordet
schickt der achtklässler eine nachricht
an einen freund jetzt nervt sie nicht
mehr nur knapp dem tod entkommen der 17
jährige max aus minden was von seiner
jugendliebe ronja bleibt ist diese
riesige narbe auf seinem bauch am 21
juli 2021 verabredet sich max für ein
anonymes date mit einer
internet-bekanntschaft doch am
vereinbarten treffpunkt erscheint ein
unbekannter mann mit kapuze der 1 13
zentimeter langes messer zückt und auf
den 17-jährigen einsticht max überlebt
die messer attacke nur knapp unfassbar
hinter dieser brutalen attacke stecken
max 16 jährige ex freundin ronja und ihr
neuer freund kai max und ronja waren
knapp ein jahr lang zusammen trennten
sich acht monate vor der messerattacke
freundschaftlich wie max beteuert ein
richter verurteilte ronja und ihren
freund kai ende mai zu mehreren jahren
haft zurück nach salzgitter der ort
trauert es ist eine tat die die stadt in
niedersachsen für lange zeit schockieren
wird
und wir begrüßen ganz herzlich kinder
und jugend therapeuten miriam hoffe
schon dass sie bei uns sind rum wir
stellen uns die frage was kann dazu
führen dass kinder das jugendliche töten
jetzt vor allem in der jetzigen zeit für
natürlich mit impuls kontroll schwächen
oftmals zu tun haben sie sind in den
letzten zweieinhalb jahren massiv
ausgesetzt gewesen den virtuellen themen
das heißt konfrontiert mit gewalt im
internet im in den medien und hatten
auch weniger möglichkeiten im außen in
sportaktivitäten es aus zu agieren ist
es natürlich keine entschuldigung man
muss halt einfach auch schauen was in
dem individuellen fall die täter
getrieben hat im endeffekt ist es so
dass es oftmals auch ein ventil ist
unterdrückt aggressionen die in anderer
stelle nicht raus kann für vollbild
modell funktionen die ein fehlerhaft
waren ein regulativ grad niemanden der
ihn einheit geboten hat und die
sozialkompetenz leider gottes und
gemischten da fehlende empathie kann
dazu wenn das nicht ausgebildet wird
dass solche grausamen taten gerade im
jugendalter eher passieren also wenn
jugendliche wenn teenies töten dass sich
was aufgestaut hat vorher und dass man
so habe ich sie verstanden auch
möglicherweise wegen der vielen computer
spielerei video spielerei man dann
kurzzeitig verwechselt was es eigentlich
realität was das virtuell
genau weil jugendliche haben im
gegensatz zu den erwachsenen noch nicht
diese weitsicht und oftmals ist in dem
alter auch die impulskontrolle noch
nicht wirklich ausgebildet noch dazu
kommt es dazu dass man sich mit
gegenseitigen challenges er ist
schneller größer wer macht sie wer
brüche und herausforderungen gegenseitig
übertrumpfen möchte und dann oftmals
nicht eingesehen wird oder erkannt wird
das ist das zuviel wo überschreiten
grenzen die nicht mehr rückgängig zu
machen ist das ist eben leider gerade im
jugendalter
weil die erfahrungen fehlen das
regulativ im außen wählte erhält durch
mangelnde vorbilder und diese
kombination gepaart mit einem stand in 7
computerkonsum dazu führen kann dass es
zu solchen schrecklichen taten kommt
welche warnzeichen gibt es denn es gibt
sicherlich ist keine blaupause kein
muster das man ganz genau eins zu eins
abfragen kann aber bei welchen
aggressiven warenzeichen muss man dann
doch hellhörig werden
es ist so dass wenn man beobachtet dass
ein kind oder ein jugendlicher sehr oft
in konflikten involviert es wenig
schuldeinsicht zeigt wenig empathie
zeigt vielleicht auch dazu neigt zum
beispiel an tieren sich auszuprobieren
tiere zu quälen
erstmals produziert
also wenn
regelverstöße in einer kurzen zeit
intensiv vorkommen wenn ein kind oder
ein jugendlicher auch selber opfer
geworden ist von intensiven mobbing wenn
es in der familie oder sehen dafür nicht
gesehen wird wenn ein fach das
selbstbewusstsein nicht ausgebildet ist
oder nicht die anerkennung bekommt dann
tun solche menschen sich teilweise in
anderen bereichen anerkennung zu suchen
und dass es oftmals mit aggression ein
leicht ist denn da bekommt die
aufmerksamkeit und die anerkennung von
gleichaltrigen so traurig es auch sagte
miriam hofft kinder und jugend
therapeutin vielen herzlichen dank ihnen
für diese information